[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre
le 28 octobre dernier
s'est tenu à Matignon sous votre
autorité
une réunion dite convention des
partenaires
consacré à l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie
en cette circonstance vous avez rappelé
avec raison qu'à l'issue du processus
référendaire l'avenir appartient
désormais au calédonien et qui leur
revenait d'élaborer un projet d'avenir
consensuel
pour y parvenir vous avez proposé la
mise en place de groupes de travail que
le ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer doit installer lors de sa
visite dans les jours prochains à Nouméa
cette initiative est utile
puisqu'elle s'inscrit dans le choix que
la Nouvelle-Calédonie a fait de rester
français
mais c'est elle suffisant
les référendums de 2018 2020 2021 on non
seulement ravivé les tensions les
divisions mais on réduit en miettes
cette exception calédonienne symbolisée
par cette fameuse poignée de mains
que ce sont donnés Jacques Lafleur et
Jean-Marie chibaou en 1988
de partenaires madame la Première
ministre nous sommes redevenus des
adversaires
j'en veux pour preuve l'absence des
mouvements indépendantistes à cette
convention dite des partenaires et
pourtant
pour élaborer ce projet d'avenir
consensuel que vous appelez vous-même de
vos vœux nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
que de renouer ces liens de confiance
car notre avenir ne se construira pas
sans l'autre ni contre l'autre
madame la Première ministre concrètement
quelles initiatives le ministre de
l'Intérieur envisagit-il de prendre lors
de son séjour à Nouméa pour que les
trois partenaires qui étaient l'État les
indépendantistes et nous nous
retrouvions en confiance merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]